[Music]
joining me today is a senior economist
for the institute of new economic
thinking whose research is focused on
economic biological and sociological
approaches to human welfare
dr. Pia Milani welcome to the Rubin
report it's great to be here it is I am
looking forward to talking to you
because we've gotten to know each other
a bit anyhow and and I enjoy your
company and you've we've had some
interesting discussions some on some
stuff that we agree on some that we
disagree on we're going to get into all
of that right here but before we get
into your work and economics and all the
heavy lifting of that you have an
interesting personal story childhood
growing up in India and and all that
stuff so so let's start there tell me a
little bit about your background okay
well I grew up in India
my mother is Jewish my father is Hindu
so I grew up Jewish within what I would
say is the closest thing to a
multicultural community that I have ever
seen
so growing up my best friend was Muslim
I'd go over to her home on Christmas to
decorate the Christmas tree my other
best friend was half Parsi half Hindu
and it really was an environment where
we didn't really even think so much
about our different backgrounds we just
all were and I didn't believe and
understand what anti-semitism was until
I left India and saw it in other
countries because it's perhaps the most
welcoming country to Jews and so it's
been really interesting for me to watch
the country change over the last 10 15
years where Hindu fundamentalism has
come in and taken over in a way that I
could never have imagined when I was
growing up there yeah it's interesting
because even though there has been a
historic Jewish community and idea for a
long long time people don't realize that
there are any Jews in India when you
tell people that they go west that come
on now a number of conversations I've
had where someone will sit across from
me in a completely straight face say I
can always recognize a Jew when I say
no idea that they're talking to right
right well somehow it's been associated
with like being white or something
although my my brother-in-law is half
Moroccan half Iraqi and used brown right
so my mother's community comes from
Syria Iraq the Middle East they call
them Sephardic Jews but technically them
its Rajee Jews and we actually had three
Jewish communities in India two of them
claim to be Lost Tribes so they've been
there since before the destruction of
the second temple and are much more
integrated in Indian lives and you know
speak the local languages and they have
their own synagogues Bombay has nine
synagogues so you know I grew up going
to one of the Sephardic synagogues they
have seven been Israeli synagogues and
you know it's the old Jewish joke where
that's the synagogue I pray at that's
the one I used to pray a prayer that's
the one I wouldn't be caught dead and
you know it really was sort of a divided
community and then we had this
horrendous attack in India a few years
ago where we had a group of 10 Pakistani
militants who landed on the shores of
Bombay and held the city hostage for I
don't know 48 hours and they went for
the Jewish community and they actually
went for the European Jewish community
that was living that was traveling
mostly through so we have a small Habad
group and they found a Habad house and
it was really horrendous but the one
effect that it did have was that it
brought the rest of the Indian Jewish
community together and we were there
very soon after that and it was so
interesting celebrating Hanukkah they
actually had this giant menorah in front
of the Gateway of India and huge police
presence but you know we were out there
and whatever little force we could
muster it's a really small community now
but we were all out there celebrating
Hanukkah together at the Gateway of
India yeah I remember when that happened
how many years ago is that roughly four
or five about five years ago yeah and I
remember reading articles about how it
wasn't just the the Jewish community
that came together but it was the entire
community that they were like we are not
going to stop being as multicultural as
as you're talking about you know in many
ways that was true
I think that's that's definitely
something that came out of that the flip
side of that is that Hindu
fundamentalism has seen this very ugly
rise in India now and you know we're now
seeing what they're calling cow debt
where they're attacking Muslims claiming
that they're carrying beef or they're
eating beef and the push is to ban the
consumption of beef because Hindus
worship the cow and you know
traditionally the job of butchering beef
has gone to Muslims but you know it's
one of these things where they're using
these the accusation of beef eating much
the way blasphemy is being used in
Pakistan so if you don't like what your
next-door neighbor is doing or you have
a property dispute you can simply claim
blasphemy and you've got a mob to take
care of them for you
similarly their lynching Muslim kids in
India with very little evidence yeah I
think we don't hear that much about that
even the idea here when you say the
phrase Hindu extremists it almost
doesn't even sound like something that
would make sense for the average
Westerner to put together it's a good
question you know I think we're so
careful about wanting to be politically
correct that we're not always willing to
look at some of the more difficult stuff
that's coming out of cultures that we
want to believe our peace-loving and you
know getting directly to some of the
issues that you know I think about when
I hear the issues that you deal with on
your show with respect to Islam and some
of the Islamic extremism that you see I
always struggle with it a little bit
because we think of Hinduism as being
such a peaceful religion and I see the
extremes within Hinduism and I see it
targeted against the Islamic community
and so it's very hard for me to look at
the text of any one religion and say
that one in particular has a problem
this one has a text that doesn't look as
horrible therefore we're not going to
have the same issues yeah and you know I
tend to have much more of a sense of
this being a social political issue
an economic issue a cultural issue I
have a much harder time seeing and just
coming out of the text because I see it
as coming from text that I see as being
really not that toxic within the Hindu
context mm-hmm
and we've talked about some of this
stuff privately and I've actually when
we spoke about I last time I did help me
frame a little bit about the way I you
know I try to be very careful with my
language and I don't ever certainly want
to be bigoted towards people and I want
to talk about ideas and all that but
it's nice hearing and experience you
know someone that's lived another
experience and oh maybe you're not
thinking of something in this particular
way or any of that so so we're going to
talk about the economic reasons that a
lot of this stuff happens because that's
why that's a lot of your researches but
tell me a little bit more so growing up
in India and then you get involved in in
economics and fields that were that were
pretty and probably still are pretty
male-dominated right yes mom very what
was I thinking you know it's interesting
it was just what I found intellectually
interesting and it was the way my mind
worked analytically and it never
occurred to me that there would be
gender issues and when I show up in a
graduate department and there are just
very few women and you know it's changed
a little bit now but especially when I
was going through it I was at the
Harvard Economics Department and Larry
Summers was actually a professor at the
department while I was there and it
wasn't until a few years later that he
ended up making comments about why one
might not see women in technical fields
as much and he had a number of comments
which got him into a fair amount of
trouble what was the thrust of what he
said um well he went through a few
different reasons he said well it
couldn't be child rearing and it
couldn't be this and it couldn't be that
and the implication was essentially that
there were intellectual differentials
between men and women and you know he
didn't say it explicitly but there was
enough there and I think my sense is
that he had probably rubbed enough
people the wrong way already by that
point that there was a desire to to push
on that
it was interesting because when I heard
this my sense is that you know I was in
the department while he was a professor
in the department and it was very clear
to me that what I was seeing was not the
straight discrimination that he was
commenting on because I think he was
pointing to the fact that he didn't
really see that kind of discrimination
and I would agree with him I don't think
that's what the problem was I think the
problem as I thought it was much more
that the female temperament is very
different than a male temperament and
there tends to be much more of a focus
amongst women towards building networks
and building relationships and if you
think about the fact that evolutionarily
women have had the job of kin work and
men have had to be more alpha and be
aggressive and be competitive it sort of
makes sense that this is the temperament
that we're bringing and men are bringing
a much more alpha temperament so you
know from the beginning I'd see the men
sitting around comparing what questions
people as how many different graduate
programs they had gotten to amongst the
top programs who was going to win the
first Nobel Prize and the women had this
different approach of let's work
together let's do our problem sets
together how do we encourage each other
but I really have to wonder then how
much of the end result in terms of the
differences that we see is an issue of
our of male-dominated fields really not
being as open to a female approach to
doing things and sort of you know a less
competitive less aggressive with
inserting yourself yeah I assume you can
see pros and cons to both of that on one
hand the competitive side perhaps of the
men go and you know how many you know
graduate students you get into this so
competition is good on the other hand
working together is also good absolutely
absolutely and you know clearly you want
to be able to encourage the risk-taking
that I think men are better at because
women tend to have a need to really
deliver on what they promised probably
because if you look at the roles we've
traditionally taken on as homemakers
mothers caregivers there is a need for
consistency and
you look at what men are doing there's
often a need for greater risk taking
because if you don't shoot for something
that you might not be able to hit you're
not necessarily going to be able to
achieve as much I believe they're both
really important but I think where we
are now is that we're in a situation
where we are so focused on one end of
the skill spectrum that we are not
necessarily incorporating some of the
other values that we want to be bringing
into the workforce and you know this
leads to so meaning what that we're so
focused on just results in or on risk
taking on competitiveness and you know I
I do think if we get into some of the
diversity issues which I assume we will
at some point I think that just in terms
of greed one needs to be thinking about
how do we tap into the great resource
that women have to offer us if you think
about the fact that out of nine hundred
odd Nobel prizes less than 50 have gone
to women you've got to imagine that
that's some huge set of resources that
were not tapping into sufficiently and
then the question is how do we build up
these resources so that we actually do
access the analytic abilities that women
are able to bring to the table even if
they don't have as much of the
temperament necessarily yeah tell me a
little bit more about your mind because
you meant you said I think my mind
always worked that way or that was what
my mind was always attracted to was
economics what does that mean so like
you're 15 like did you think you know
like you really cared about this kind of
stuff I really did so when I was very
young my father used to do some
nonprofit work on family planning so he
had a regular business but he was this
was what he was doing philanthropically
and I remember sitting at the dining
table talking about the issue of
population growth and how do we actually
think about and it was the first time
that I started thinking in terms of
opportunity cost so it turns out the
best way to reduce population growth is
to educate women so that they have a
higher opportunity cost of having sure
and you see this happening naturally as
countries develop but to the extent that
you can encourage it it's one of the
most effective ways of increasing birth
control and increasing improving family
planning and you know just this concept
that if you think one level deeper you
start thinking in terms of opportunity
cause you start thinking in terms of
marginal costs on just the entire sort
of economic toolkit and how that leads
you to think about incentives was very
much the way my mind worked that's
interesting so then you got your
doctorate in economics at Harvard you
say Harvard people get all these it's
almost like it's become like Hogwarts in
a weird way you know to be like people
think it's like this this mythical place
what was it like for you there or what
if you had to just describe Harvard
because I just feel like it just has
this connotations attached to it that
people don't associate with other
colleges it's like an other thing
altogether well that's interesting I
sort of see where it comes from
if nothing else because they have access
to such an impressive application pool
applicant pool that the people they let
in you're in an environment which is
very intellectually alive so you know
some of the best conversations I've ever
had was sitting around the dining table
of friends when I was in graduate school
because just the level of discourse is
so exposed and conscious of what's going
on in the world an erudite and you just
you can just tap into a different level
of conversation you know sitting in a
cafe in Harvard Square you hear
conversations all around you which are
fascinating that being said my actual
experience within the Economics
Department was considerably less present
and um and I remember someone saying to
me that if you're not depressed in
graduate school you're not doing it
correctly but it really was quite
extreme I ran into it is that mostly
because of the workload er because it
was that did that have something to do
with being a woman in a
dominated fields or just behind that was
part of it I think a big part of it was
when I started working on my
dissertation I ran up against some of
the deep cultural issues that economics
faces and I think I really wasn't ready
for it I think I was somewhat oblivious
to just what happens within mainstream
economics departments and how
constrained one is in terms of how one
is able to think and what one is allowed
to talk about and this seems to be a
trend in a lot of the things that I talk
about on this show about what you can
talk about what you can't talk about how
you will be treated if you talk about
things that you know people don't want
you to talk about that's right and you
know this is why working at AI net for
me has been such a revelation because I
was really interested in the heterodox
economics and there really wasn't a
community back then and it's only post
2008 since the creation of AI net that I
feel like we just have this ability to
gather heterodox economists from
everywhere so that we actually believe
that they're in office I so there's a
community that we have the freedom to be
able to to think and talk about the sort
of stuff amongst our community which has
been just really wonderful there's that
community thing again so it says it does
have some value all right yes so now
let's get into some some economic sure I
thought to start a conversation about
economics I took econ 101 a long time
ago didn't do particularly well math in
general is not my thing I like the
social sciences more for my audience
that's watching it really doesn't care
particularly about economics or know
that much but the little carries can we
do some like basic economics if someone
says you what what is economics give me
a few different so my kids asked me this
and one thing that I always say to them
is try not to think about economics as a
study of money because that's really the
most limited and probably incorrect way
of thinking about it it's really the
study of incentives and when you think
about you know the two concepts that I
mentioned earlier I think really drive
my understanding of the field the
concept of opportunity cost and the
concept of thinking and marginal terms
so once you understand
diminishing marginal utility for example
how every additional unit is a good that
you consume it means just that much less
to you so you know these are very simple
concepts but defined so much of how we
actually behave in the world and you
know one of the ways that I've talked
about it is that you can think of what's
really fascinating about the subject to
me is that you can start with five very
simple assumptions on human behavior you
can assume that you have rational human
beings you have perfect information that
you have freedom of entry and exit you
know if I very simple assumptions you
can make and something miraculous
happens which is that it allows you to
tap into an entire world of mathematics
which you can then impose on human
behavior and you can set up models so
that you can actually try to understand
how people will behave and you can
understand how markets will behave based
on individual behavior and there's
something really amazing about the idea
that you can take something as messy as
human behavior and link it to something
as pure as mathematics
and actually get an understanding of how
our world works yeah which is the thing
that I found really amazing the problem
with that is that these assumptions
because they're so simple don't quite
capture human behavior sufficiently and
it gets you to the point where you can
create models that capture some things
very effectively but also lead you down
some paths that are probably not correct
and it also very interestingly ends up
leading you toward certain political
orientations and it's interesting how a
mathematical framework sort of pushes
you politically towards a particular
direction but what it really does is
that it holds up the idea of efficiency
above everything else because what
you're trying to do then is you're
trying to maximize efficiency that is
what economists hold is the holy grail
and so then we get very focused on this
concept of efficiency and it turns out
that there's sort of a trade-off between
efficiency and distribution equality
inequality and because these economies
get so caught up in the beauty of what
it takes to get efficiency we lose track
of the other side of this and so while I
started off being fascinated by what we
call the neoclassical model which is
just this very simple form of economics
that you get from thinking and marginal
terms and being a being able to apply
calculus because we're thinking in
marginal terms just starting to try and
understand what are the assumptions that
maybe we are not in a position to make
where are we going wrong what are some
of the other things that we need to
bring in and you know that leads you to
an entirely different way of thinking
about the economy and this is why I had
talks economics is so much more
interesting to me now interesting so
it's funny I'm always very upfront with
my audience there are certain guests
that I try to do a little less research
with because I want to go in with sort
of a really blank slate and ask sort of
the simpler questions there are some
guess that I have to do a little more
research on or know a specific quote or
a chronology of something and for you
you definitely for me we're one of the
people that had to do more research on
and read more of the stuff that you've
done because I wanted to have a handle
on it enough to ask the right questions
so you wrote a really interesting piece
on the economics of despair and I read
it now three or four times actually and
I thought it does sum up so much of
what's happening right now in the
political system it shows to me it shows
the the truth true through line between
economics and politics so first off can
you can you recap what the with the
piece was sure so this was actually
really interesting to me because about
15 20 years ago I was looking at Russia
post collapse of the Soviet Union and
what we were finding was that there was
a mortality crisis death rates amongst
middle-aged white men
were rising dramatically and when we
started looking at what the causes were
it was essentially people drinking
himself to death because their lives had
suddenly become so uncertain their
economy had collapsed they had no idea
how to transition to this new way of
being and they were just lost and so you
know heart attacks were on the rise
alcohol poisoning was on the rise and it
was very much the sense that these were
debts of despair and I hadn't looked at
that work for a long time and then
recently on to Princeton economist Angus
Deaton in an case came out with some
research looking at how mortality is
actually starting to increase amongst
lower middle class white men in this
country and the more they exported it
was fascinating to me it was exactly the
same phenomenon that we were seeing in
Russia post collapse of the Soviet Union
and you know it's what they have term
debts of despair the opioid epidemic
alcohol suicides heart attacks and it's
really the burden is falling amongst
whites with a high school education or
lower and so then the question is what
is causing this and to me this was
linking directly with some of the other
stuff that we have been talking about
with respect to politics with this
question of what's happening in Rust
Belt America yeah what is the sudden
rise in population than any other now is
populism and you know what is driving
this where is this coming from and if
you look at what's happening to the
lives of these people you're seeing
really of collapse of an economic system
that they knew and you're seeing a
decline in wages and no ability or
thought that they can see to climbing
out of this and this tide so closely
with what I was seeing happening
politically so if you just look at some
of the numbers coming out of there in
this last election
many of the counties that voted for
Obama in Wisconsin and in Michigan ended
up voting for Trump in this last
election and if you look at which
counties in particular when from Obama
to Trump in so many of the cases in a
huge majority of the cases they were
counties that had voted for Bernie
Sanders and the primaries and to me this
was saying look you're seeing populism
on the left you're seeing populism on
the right there is something that is
driving this way of thinking on both
sides of this and there is a similarity
that where somehow not understanding and
I know you've used the word economic
nationalism a fair amount in in your
talks and to me it was really this
question of when did economic
nationalism go from being a
fundamentally Democratic bastion to
something that we're hearing from the
mouth of Steve Danon and we're hearing
from Trump's people and there really is
some kind of an overlap that we're
seeing where we're seeing I think the
same issues of despair coming in the
face of globalization and the collapse
of the manufacturing sector that is
driving a lot of the politics in this
country today yeah so there's so much
there we go in a thousand different
directions yeah what strikes me
immediately is that it's sort of like
Trump had a very keen understanding of
that which is why he kept saying during
the primaries you see the way Hillary's
treating Bernie because he was trying to
give a signal to the Bernie guys going
even once she takes him out which she
was going to do one way or another I'm
your guy not her so do you think he
really had an awareness of that sort of
at the economic level or was that just
sort of realpolitik in his mind do you
think I know I know you're not a Trump
psychiatrist I'm not a Trump
psychiatrist do you take a lot of money
is it from psychiatrist now can you
touch that one I think that it was
increasingly clear to a lot of people
who were looking at this that the
rank-and-file of the Democratic Party
was very very dissolution
with what we were seeing coming from
them and you know there's another whole
area that I would want to talk about
which is the investment theory of party
competition that was developed by Tom
Ferguson and some of my colleagues where
the idea is really that at some point it
became so expensive to run a campaign
that the only way to do it was to get a
tremendous amount of money in from
corporate America the billionaire class
and I think that really changed the
conversation that was happening within
the Democratic Party I think it has been
very much the conversation that's been
happening in the Republican Party for a
long time and I think Bernie was able to
tap into something and I think Trump
understood very clearly that there was
this populist rising he was able to tap
into it too now I will say that even
though a lot of Trump counties sorry the
Obama counties that went for Trump or
Bernie supporters there was another
statistic that I found fascinating which
was that in Michigan there were
apparently 80,000 ballots that people
had filled out where they had filled out
both sides of the ballot and they had
left the space for president blank and
to me this is a very strong indication
if you think about the fact that Trump
won Michigan by 10,000 votes we're
talking about $80,000 yeah this is a
very strong indication that this was
people who were just really fed up with
what they see happening at the
conversation with both these parties you
know they just have the sense of none of
this is real and my sense about it is
that they're actually correct and when I
hear liberal economists talk about what
happened in the wake of the election I'm
hearing a fair amount of stuff which
talks about akhada what was it the other
day I heard someone on duremar say the
knuckle-dragging Midwesterners of
something like this and you know there's
just this idea they've been had Trump
promised them something he's never going
to give them things that he promised you
know for all I know that may be true I
don't know that he's actually going to
come through and you know if you ask me
I'd say it's probably unlikely that he'd
come through on some of his more
nationalist promises I think create an
immigration or the first you know
immigration he may actually push hard on
but with respect to trade I think
there's just too much political support
and financial support that he's going to
get that pushes him away from his
economic nationalist arguments but I
think it was very clear that the people
who were reacting this way were just
sick of the VISAA were coming from both
sides with respect to real economic
issues with respect to trade with
respect to immigration with respect to
financial globalization just all of
these things which have really been very
bad for lower middle-class America
[Music]
you
[Music]